[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and this
is the unboxing and some first
impressions of the brand new nexus 10
tablet from samsung and google so what
better place to start than the outside
of the box here and you can see the
design is pretty similar to that of the
nexus 7 box and the nexus 4 and you can
have your google nexus logo and samsung
logo peacefully on the side of the box
no problem and on the back you do get a
little bit of a write up about the
device and google play but without any
further ado let's go ahead and get into
the unboxing itself and you can see the
outside is just a sleeve so the inside
box is this sleek black and you go ahead
and open it up and right on top of
course is the nexus 10. so we'll go
ahead and move this guy to the side just
for a second because there are a few
things behind this baus tablet and
that'll be your usb charging and data
cable and the charging adapter for you
the wall in whatever country you're in
and a little bit of paperwork just a
little bit and of course after the
unboxing be gone with the protective
plastic on both sides of the tablet and
let's get into this all right so first
impressions of this product without even
having turned it on yet of this hardware
is that it is built pretty well uh first
thing that sticks out at me is the front
facing speakers on the sides that's
probably going to be really nice and
something else also is this front facing
camera is a little bit off to this to
the right hand side so it's not quite
center but that's no big deal flipping
around to the back i love this back this
texture is surprisingly tacky you can
probably see that nexus logo here but
it's surprisingly tacky so you can grip
it with one hand no big deal and of
course the camera also happens to have a
flash next to it which is cool and a
microphone but i'm gonna go ahead and
without any further ado turn the device
on for the first time of course you can
see up top or the power button and the
volume keys and on the bottom down here
is your pogo pins and of course charging
will happen over here on the left hand
side and uh there's also a three and a
half millimeter headphone jack but of
course i'm holding down the power button
to get a first look at the display as it
turns on that was a little weird got
some snow at the bottom ah but there's
the nexus logo and we are booting up the
nexus 10 for the first time so it's
strikingly noticeable that the webcam is
to the side that was fast that was
really fast okay
uh well we're going to go right ahead
and set up the nexus 10 we'll go ahead
and walk through the setup process here
for english in the united states and i'm
going to connect to wi-fi now connecting
and i'm guessing it's going to ask me
for my google account information which
i also won't be showing you but i will
show you that screen anyway
yep so it's asking god google i'm gonna
go ahead and put in my email and stuff
now all right so it's asking me if i
want to back up and restore i don't want
to restore anything right now but i
definitely want to keep this tablet
backed up to my google account i want to
use google's wi-fi or google's location
and wi-fi and setup is already complete
and uh of course it's going to have a
gigantic google play widget and we
already are in android 4.2 jellybean my
first impressions of the keyboard as i
was putting in usernames and passwords
of stuff was that it was really
responsive it does have a motor inside
which will vibrate so if you have a
vibrating notifications you'll get those
as well of course we can see all the way
on the right hand side is our quick
settings and we can scroll that down and
it'll slide back up and we have our
regular notifications so we have a bunch
of updates in the play store which i'll
get to in a second and we have this
magnificent
2560 by 1600 display so i'll go ahead
and move around here through the
notifications and the app drawer and all
kinds of things and right off the bat
it's obviously really smooth project
butter is of course present here and
let's go into our settings and check out
that jelly bean easter egg
about tablet android 4.2
looking good on this display i gotta say
i'm immediately impressed with uh the
2560 by 1600 resolution and i'm going to
be getting some close-up shots with this
of course in the full review video but
the point of me asking you this right
now is i want to see what you guys want
to see in the full review video i want
to know what you guys
are excited to see what you want to see
more information about you know maybe
it's battery life maybe it's web
browsing performance gaming let me know
because this is how i get all the
information to provide reviews for you
guys so definitely let me know what
you're thinking uh of course here we
have google now we're going to go ahead
and hit next because i of course want
google now
to give me all these cards to be useful
i'm in show me my teams show me stocks
of course all this stuff is very useful
either way thank you for watching this
unboxing video of course if you're ready
for the review video or if you want to
see more videos like this hit that
subscribe button up there
and i will talk to you guys in the very
next one
peace
[Music]
you